das war eine turbulente erste woche des
jahres mit den ereignissen in den usa
und den beschlüssen des treffens der
länderchefs in und chefs mit der
bundesregierung am dienstag also lassen
sie uns auf letzteres auf groner zum
ende der woche noch einmal mit einer der
beteiligten schauen
schönen guten morgen war 3
ministerpräsidentin von rheinland pfalz
malu dreyer ich möchte mit ihnen zurück
auf die beschlüsse der woche schauen und
natürlich nach vorne was das ganze für
unser leben heißt auch sie in
rheinland-pfalz haben ja angekündigt
dass die bewegungsfreiheit in hotspots
mit einem incidents wert von über 200
eingeschränkt werden kann auf maximal 15
kilometer dann vom wohnort mal ganz
grundsätzlich wieviel bürgerrechte sind
aus ihrer sicht einschränkt um darauf zu
hoffen dass dadurch die für ausbreitung
des virus eingeschränkt wird das kann
man natürlich gar nicht allgemein
beantworten sondern man muss bei jeder
maßnahme wirklich schauen ob sie
verhältnismäßig erforderlich ist und ob
sie wirklich auch etwas bringt das
beispiel was ich gelernt habe auch in
der runde ist es bei spielsachen
thüringen das dann thüringen darum
gebeten hat das sachsen diesen radius
beschränkt weil die sachsen eine sehr
hohe intelligenz hatten und viele der
sachsen da die thüringer wald
touristische ausflüge gemacht haben und
das ist ja nachvollziehbar ich glaube
auch verfassungsmäßig überhaupt gar
nicht zu beanstanden und auch
erforderlich bei diesen zahlen und
dementsprechend muss man jetzt bei der
umsetzung geben dann immer auch sehr
genau prüfen in der jeweiligen region
sind diese grundsätze eingehalten und
dann kann man die maßnahmen nach
ergreifen und zum schutz der bevölkerung
es ist aus ihrer sicht lich auch wichtig
gerade in der jetzigen zeit dass die
menschen eben auch ausgehen können dass
die menschen so zu sagen dieses kleine
stück freiheitsgefühl dass er sowieso
schon stark eingeschränkt ist zumindest
ein bisschen behalten können das ist
ganz unbedingt wichtig deshalb gibt es
ja auch nur den ganz wenigen fällen in
deutschland eine sogenannte
ausgangssperren und die meistens dann ja
nur nachts nur an ganz bestimmten
punkten wo die inzidenz sehr sehr hoch
ist nein natürlich
die bevölkerung hat sie ein wenig
spielräume dinge zu tun und raus an die
luft spazierengehen das ist natürlich
erforderlich aber was wir nicht wollen
ist das ganz ganz viele menschen tages
touristische ausflüge machen wo sie dann
einfach gewalt zusammen sind und das
sollte man einfach vermeiden es passt
nicht in die zeit wir müssen schauen
dass die inzidenz zahl nach unten gehen
nächste massive einschränkungen ist beim
schulbetrieb bei ihnen in rheinland
pfalz gibt es bis mindestens 25 januar
fernunterricht nur abschlussklassen
dürfen eingeteilten gruppen kommen ihre
bildungsministerin stefanie huber
die hätte sich mehr präsenz gewünscht
dass hätten aber sagt sie die beschlüsse
des bund länder treffen treffens nicht
zugelassen das gleiche hat mir gestern
hier bei phoenix die nrw schulministerin
über und gebauer gesagt und die hat
gesagt der 31 erste das muss das maximum
sein danach muss wie der präsenz her um
das bildungsrecht der schüler zu
gewährleisten
sind sie dafür dass am ersten februar
die schüler in deutschland wieder zurück
in die klassen dürfen ja absolut also es
ist tatsächlich eine ganz ganz schwere
hürde finde ich dass schüler an
schülerinnen so wenig jetzt im
präsenzunterricht sein können natürlich
dann sind wir alle sehr bemüht darum
dass der fan unterricht gut gelingt
dennoch schülern schülerin brauchen die
präsenz in der schule und auch wir gehen
davon aus dass wir ab dem ersten februar
den beschluss der kultusminister
umsetzen werden und je nach incidents
eben wieder sehr viel stärker auch
präsenzunterricht anbieten
gerade für die kleinen ist es wirklich
außerordentlich wichtig dass sie auch
immer wieder in kontakt mit mitschülern
sind und eben auch mit ihren lehrern und
lehrerinnen
das ist auch eine große anforderungen an
die familien jetzt wieder
wir haben jetzt bis 25 jahren unterricht
verlängert aber wir wollen auch je nach
intention kann man dann auch in wechsel
unterricht gehen ohne dass man die
präsenz voraussetzt
also verpflichtend macht es gibt ja
beschluss auch her der beschluss ist ein
stück offen dennoch wir halten uns an
diese beschlüsse vom dezember und wir
wollen das auch
dem ersten februar wirklich den menschen
dann die kinder dann eben auch wieder
entsprechendes kmk beschluss ist mehr
präsenz in der schule haben und kurze
rückfrage dazu gilt das dann auch eben
dann am ersten februar das in zweifel
das recht der kinder eben wieder die
schuld zu werden in den schulen auch im
zweifel ein stück weit höher ist als
eben zu sagen wir müssen die
gesamtbevölkerung von einer höheren
instanz schützen ich finde das recht auf
bildung ist ein ganz ganz viel wert und
es muss auch immer im blick behalten
werden
wie lange es eigentlich die dauer
solcher maßnahmen und die dauer ist dann
schon verdammt lang weil die kinder ja
auch in den ferien vorher waren und
deshalb ist es wirklich so dass ab dem
ersten februar ist ganz wichtig ist dass
die kinder gerade jüngeren auf jeden
fall wieder im präsent sind die älteren
dann vielleicht noch im wechsel
unterricht aber die kleineren müssen auf
jeden fall dann auch wieder im
präsenzunterricht oder die möglichkeit
dazu haben noch ein beschluss von
dienstag wenn wir auf die regel schauen
dass ab montag ein haushalt nur noch
eine weitere person treffen darf da
haben wir viele zuschauer geschrieben
dass sie das nicht verstehen wie das
gehen soll
man darf also oma und opa zum beispiel
nicht mehr treffen was ist mit all den
patchwork familien wenn kinder zu einem
anderen elternteil mit neue familie
wollen oder wenn jemand beispielsweise
seine zwei schwestern treffen will geht
das alles ja gar nicht macht die regel
so aus ihrer sicht sind also die regel
ist sehr sehr hart sie entspricht der
regelung die wir im ersten lockdown märz
hatten und sie hat eigentlich nur eine
einzige funktion nämlich die kontakte
zum minimal zu halten wie möglich wir
selber diskutieren dem kabinett und ich
habe auch vorgeschlagen dass wir für die
ganz kleinen kindern wird es ja weiter
auch eine ausnahme machen unter sechs
mal ist natürlich gar nicht geht dass
kinder gar kein kind mehr treffen aber
eine zweijährige kann ich halt nicht an
die tür des freundes und des nachbarns
schicken alleine ohne dass die mama
dabei ist also da muss man einfach das
ist in meiner oma und opa wäre dann
trotzdem nicht möglich hartz iv familien
würden nicht profitieren und was ist mit
denen über sechs können sie sich das
vorstellen dass da noch einmal
nachjustiert werden muss und dass diese
regel gegebenenfalls doch im nächsten
zwei wochen noch einmal aufgehoben
werden muss wir diskutieren im land ins
gerade
konkret wie wir es umsetzen werden in
der rechtsverordnung um trotzdem gegen
geister regelung gerecht zu werden aber
auch die regelung alltags praktisch zu
gestalten das ist die diskussion gerade
in unserem land es war ein punkt den wir
nochmals sehr intensive angesprochen
hatten in der bundeskanzler runde
ich persönlich war immer der meinung
dass man gut hätte leben können mit der
regelung dass die unter zwölfjährigen
auch nicht mitgezählt werden das war
dann aber kein konsens in der runde und
der konsens war es auch wichtig also
nehmen wir jetzt diesen auftrag auch
anschauen aber dass er gerade für die
ganz kleinen kinder auch lebens
praktisch umzusetzen sein wird und dann
lassen sie uns zum ende noch über das
letzte aufreger thema vieler menschen
derzeit sprechen die impfstrategie seit
gestern wird in rheinland pfalz in den
31 impfzentren mit 36 so genannten
straßen geimpft davor ging es ja schon
mit wie im rest deutschlands auch mit
mobilen teams los sind sie zufrieden mit
der beschaffung von impfstoff und der
organisation oder kritisieren sie wie
viele ihrer spd-kollegen ja schon vorher
den gesundheitsministerien sparen ich
finde dass das thema kein aufreger thema
ist sondern ein hoffnungsschimmer ist
ich bin glücklich darüber dass wir jetzt
den impfstoff haben wir haben gestern
mit den nebenstraßen begonnen wir haben
jetzt insgesamt über 20.000 menschen
geimpft und das wird jetzt mit hochdruck
weitergehen und sein ziel ist es am ende
des monats 100000 reinfeldt am rheinland
pfälzerin geimpft zu haben und natürlich
kann man sich streiten aber ich blicke
jetzt in die zukunft wir haben auch das
versprechen dass ich die bundeskanzlerin
und herr sparen noch mal ganz intensiv
dafür ein selbst ob es möglicherweise
auch noch mehr impfstoff gibt jetzt
wissen wir moderner mit auch auf dem
markt kommen wir werden alles tun um den
ganzen impfstoff der vorhanden ist so
schnell wie möglich den hilfsbereiten
bürgern und bürgerinnen zur verfügung zu
stellen und zu impfen und heute bekommen
die bundesländer ja auch noch mal eine
neue lieferung von etwa knapp 668.000
impfstoffen von impfdosen von biontech
frau dreyer vielen dank ihnen für dieses
gespräch hier bei phoenix im
tagesgespräch
ich danke ihnen der bauerntag ihnen auch